-Several prominent Republicans
are continuing to push back
against both mask rules
and COVID vaccines,
even though we now
have significant evidence
that the vaccines cut down
on transmission,
can help protect others,
and get us back to normal.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
When it comes to masks
and vaccinations,
there have been a lot
of dumb opinions.
For example, yesterday, former
GOP Congressman Jason Chaffetz,
who's now
a Fox News contributor,
trotted out what
he apparently thought
was a brilliant analogy
to criticize mandates.
-I think one of the principles
that people just tend
to forget about,
which is the proper role
of government.
The proper role of government,
is to inform the public,
but we believe, in the
United States of America,
about self-determination,
that we get to make
those decisions.
-Yes.
-The government can help
provide the information,
they have
a Centers for Disease Control,
but there are lots of diseases
that kids can potentially get.
I mean, we could all not die
driving down the freeway
at 55 or 70 or 80 miles an hour,
if we all drove
three miles an hour.
But you know what?
We put the warnings up there.
We put a speed limit up there.
We say, "We'd rather
you not do this."
And there are consequences
and some people, you know,
suffer those consequences.
But self-determination
is the principle, here.
-Ooh, I hate to be one
of those speed limit signs
you seem to hate,
but slow down, pal.
First of all,
do you think speed limits
are just suggestions?
If that were the case,
wouldn't the signs be phrased
a little differently?
Also, the proper role
of government
isn't just to inform the public.
Sure, it's one of the roles.
You want them to inform,
but you also want them to act.
FDR didn't give
a Fireside Chat in 1940
saying, "Paris has fallen
to Nazi Germany.
Please let us know
how you'd like us to proceed."
Also, I love how he
accidentally backed himself
into arguing for mandates
when he admitted
there are consequences
for breaking the speed limit.
A rule set by the government
that has consequences
for breaking it?
That's a mandate, bro.
You sound like a guy
just spit-balling an argument
for an open marriage.
"Monogamy is a construct.
When the priest said,
'Do you take this woman?',
he wasn't pointing at anybody."
So there are a lot of dumb
takes out there
about masks and vaccines.
By far, the worst take,
so far, came
from Marjorie Taylor Greene,
whose every utterance
sounds like it's coming
from someone
being dragged backwards
out of a Costco,
grabbing at the DVD rack.
She's like the lady
at the PTA meeting
who argues that math
violates the Constitution.
"According
to the First Amendment,
two plus two equals
whatever I say it does!"
Ma'am, do you even have
a child at the school?
"Oh, I guess I need children
to have an opinion
on the curriculum
for a school two towns
over from mine?
I didn't know I was living
in Soviet Russia."
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
has decided
to keep the House's
massive mandate in place
until more Republicans
get vaccinated
because so many
have apparently refused.
In a recent survey, for example,
CNN found that...
Meanwhile...
So, Pelosi said she'll keep
the House mask mandate
in place for now
an, in response,
Greene, who has a history
of anti-Semitism,
used an absolutely insane
and grotesque analogy.
-This woman is mentally ill.
You know, we can look back
in a time in history
where people were told
to wear a gold star
and they were definitely treated
like second-class citizens,
so much so that
they were put in trains
and taken to gas chambers
in Nazi Germany,
and this is exactly
the type of abuse
that Nancy Pelosi
is talking about.
-She's mentally ill?
You just compared having
to wear a mask
to prevent transmission
of a highly contagious
respiratory illness
to the Holocaust.
I'd say you should be
wearing a straitjacket,
but, with you, I'm guessing
a normal jacket put on backwards
would probably do the trick.
"How do I get out of this?!
The antifa Democrats have
trapped me in a windbreaker!
This is just like Nazi Germany!"
I mean, holy [bleep]
As a general rule --
and this goes for everyone --
don't compare anything
to the Holocaust, ever,
especially if you're the lady
who famously said
wildfires are caused
by Jewish space lasers.
Who knows?
Maybe that'll be your excuse.
"I want to apologize
for my comments
comparing masks
to the Holocaust.
I don't know what got into me,
but I expect it was
a ray beam
from a Jewish space laser.
Do not wrestle the mic
away from me.
I'm making a very good point."
Now, obviously,
the CDC guidance on masks
for fully vaccinated
people has changed.
That guidance is informed
by growing scientific evidence,
as well as increasing
vaccination rates,
which is why it's so frustrating
that so many Republicans,
in Congress
and throughout the country,
have said they won't
get vaccinated.
Now, we've all been living
with this pandemic
for 16 months, now,
and it's obviously
changed our behavior
in some pretty dramatic ways,
which is totally understandable.
I mean, early on, we all thought
we could catch COVID
from our mail or our doorknobs.
The science pretty quickly
showed us those scenarios
are very unlikely,
but that hasn't stopped my wife
from putting the mail
in the microwave
and putting the microwave
in the dishwasher.
No one --
[ Laughter ]
I should stress, no one --
was more relieved to me
to find out it was unlikely
to transmit via mail
because, a bunch of times,
I told my wife
I had wiped down the mail
when, in fact, I had not.
[ Laughter ]
I just reached a breaking point
where I would've preferred dying
to wiping down the mail again.
It also did not help
that my mom -- true story --
decided to send my kids a letter
a day for the entire pandemic.
[ Laughter ]
An incredible act of love
from a grandmother,
but a total failure
to consider the circumstances.
The only thing that could've
been more terrifying is
if she'd tied each letter
to a brick
and chucked it
through our window.
[ Laughter ]
But she's the best
and I can't stay mad at her.
Anyway, the point is
it takes time
to break the habits
we've all formed
during the pandemic,
like mask wearing.
I've been fully vaccinated
for a while, now,
and I still don't feel
totally comfortable
showing people the lower
half of my face.
It's like being the first person
to take your shirt off
at a pool party.
Like we all know we have to take
our shirts off, at some point,
but being the first one
to do so is still weird.
So then you start chanting
someone else's name,
to make them go first,
and then, he does
and he has a weird scar
and then you feel bad
and it's still three hours
before your mom
is due to pick you up.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway.
I'm sorry, Dave.
That was not cool of me.
[ Laughter ]
So, naturally, a lot of us
were a little taken aback,
at first,
when the CDC announced
a major shift earlier this month
and said fully vaccinated adults
no longer need to wear masks,
outdoors or indoors.
Even businesses were unsure
how to react, at first,
which left a lot
of people confused.
-A huge shift in life
as we have known it
for the last year and change.
If you are fully vaccinated,
the CDC now says,
you can now ditch your mask,
outdoors and indoors.
But again, that's only if you've
been fully vaccinated.
-Tonight, at least 18 states
already lifting
their mask mandates.
But there are many businesses
across the country
still concerned, still hoping
customers will wear masks.
Many businesses still
deciding what they'll do.
Kroger, for one, saying they
will keep the mask mandate.
Target and Home Depot
doing the same.
But Walmart tonight saying
they'll drop the masks.
Trader Joe's was the first
major grocery store
to drop the mask mandate today,
as long as shoppers
are vaccinated.
-First of all, I think
it's Kroger's, not Kroger.
[ Laughter ]
Second of all, of course
Trader Joe's was the first.
I'm honestly shocked
Trader Joe's
had any rules at all,
let alone a mask mandate.
It's like if Jimmy Buffett
were a grocery store.
One time, I bought some of their
Everything but the Bagel
seasoning
and it didn't have
a price on it,
so I asked the cashier how much
it cost and they said,
"Whatever you want
to pay for it."
And then, they whispered,
"You want to do a line?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "A line
of Everything but the Bagel
seasoning?"
And they said,
"No, man, I'm just kidding."
But I, for real,
don't think they were.
[ Laughter ]
The point is, it's confusing
and everyone's doing their best.
Even when you go get coffee,
you can see people trying
to thread the needle.
Like they have a mask
around their ear
or below their mouth
or my personal favorite --
the wrist mask -- as if to say,
"I'm not going to wear it,
but I know about it."
And, look,
it's a complicated situation
and the science
is always evolving
and there are differing views
among epidemiologists
and policymakers
about the best path forward.
A lot of scientists
were expecting this guidance
and agree with it,
but they just thought
it would come a little later
this summer,
instead of earlier this month.
-I think what happened was
the CDC kind of got ahead
of everyone a little bit
and did it sooner
than most of us thought.
So I was expecting this
sometime in June.
It's a couple of weeks early.
I think it'll be okay.
But I think the stores,
the businesses,
the universities,
need a little time to catch up
and have some
internal discussions.
And, over time, over the summer,
as more and more people
get vaccinated,
as virus transmission
continues to decline,
people will have more
of a comfort level
with the new guidance.
-It's true. The guidance
might've come a little early,
but, eventually, hopefully,
it'll work itself out
and people will get
comfortable with it.
I know it's going
to take me some time.
I mean, for one thing,
I'm still shocked,
just to find out
what the entirety
of people's faces look like.
I thought it would be thrilling
to see the lower halves
of the folks I met
during the pandemic
and, instead, I'm shocked to see
how little they match
my expectations.
It turns out the eyes
are no indicator
of what's happening
from the nostril to the chin.
This has been my reaction
to every person
upon seeing their mouth
for the first time --
Huh!
[ Laughter ]
Not what I would've thought!
In some cases,
the bottom half reveal
can completely change
how you feel about a person.
Like I found out my new dentist
has a soul patch and, now,
[ Laughter ]
I'm starting to doubt
the benefits of flossing.
By the way, if you go somewhere
and they still have
a mask policy,
don't be one of those people
who thinks it's their
"Don't Tread on Me" moment.
You're not Ethan Allen
and this isn't Fort Ticonderoga.
Just be cool and wear your mask.
The key here is vaccination.
That's what's
making this possible.
About 60% of adults
have received at least one dose
and the Biden administration
has set a goal
of getting at least one dose
to 70% of Americans by July 4th.
And there's two reasons
for that.
One, you're protecting yourself.
And two, the science is now
telling us
these vaccines are so effective,
you're also protecting others.
Because it's not just
that the vaccines
are very likely
to keep you from getting sick.
There's now growing evidence
that they also strongly
curb transmission,
meaning that,
if you get vaccinated,
you're very unlikely to spread
coronavirus to others,
and that, that is huge.
Since we started vaccinating
people en masse
and collecting real-world data,
it became very clear that,
not only were vaccines
really good at keeping people
from getting sick,
they were also really good
at keeping people
from getting infected --
because you could be infected
without getting sick.
But then,
the third component was that,
even if you did get
an infection,
even if you tested positive
for COVID
after having been vaccinated,
it was very unlikely
you'd ever develop
enough virus in your body
to then transmit it to others.
-There's a new piece of science,
and this is coming out of Israel
earlier this month,
that's showing that
vaccinated individuals,
if they do get
asymptomatic infection,
it's about 90% protective
against asymptomatic infection.
If they do get
asymptomatic infection,
they're not shedding very much
virus from their nose and mouth,
so, even though they have
asymptomatic infection,
we think they're not actually
transmitting the virus,
and that's
really important news.
-After this pandemic is over,
I never want to hear
about shedding
from any orifice, ever again.
Sounds like
some weird drug slang
you'd hear at a rave
in Williamsburg.
"Hey, man, do you shed
from the nose or the mouth?"
Neither. I just do
Everything but the Bagel
seasoning.
[ Laughter ]
But that's how it works.
When you get coronavirus
and you're not vaccinated,
the virus develops in your body
and you shed
from your nose and mouth.
And, if you have an especially
high viral load,
you can shed a lot.
And, if you're indoors,
with no ventilation and no masks
and multiple people are
potentially shedding the virus,
that's how you get
superspreader events,
especially if you're surrounded
by a family of germ factory
mouth-breathers,
like the Olympic bobshed team,
over here.
Their noses flare like the
mainsails of a mighty schooner.
These dudes are such heavy
mouth-breathers,
when they suck in air,
they sound like
a Dyson Airblade.
This is why vaccination
is the key
to getting rid of masks
and it's also why it's a problem
that so many Republicans
in Congress, and in polls,
said they won't get vaccinated.
Now, to their credit,
some Republican politicians
have put out videos urging
people to take the vaccine,
like Louisiana
Senator John Kennedy, although,
I'm not sure how effective
his messaging has been.
-♪ Born free ♪
♪ As free as the wind blows ♪
♪ As free
as the grass grows ♪
♪ Born free
to follow your heart ♪
♪ Live free ♪
♪ And beauty surrounds you ♪
♪ The world still astounds you ♪
♪ Each time you look at a star ♪
I'm Senator John Kennedy.
I can't sing very well,
but I'm free.
Be free. Be cool.
Get the vaccine.
I did.
[ Laughter ]
It works.
-Are you ready to go,
Senator Kennedy?
[ As Kennedy ]
I am, but I'm going to do
the whole verse.
[ Laughter ]
We don't think -- You don't need
to do the whole --
I think, if we just get
"Born free" out there,
it will be fine with that.
[ As Kennedy ]
I'm going to do the whole verse.
[ Laughter ]
Is tone-deafness one
of the side effects?
[ Laughter ]
You sound like
a dying cat.
I'm not sure
if I should congratulate you
for being pro-vaccine
or rush you to the vet.
I can't believe
I'm saying this, but,
maybe take singing lessons
from Chuck Schumer?
-♪ Right at the very
start of it ♪
♪ New York, New York ♪
-[ As Schumer ]
New York is back, baby!
[ Laughter ]
We may not have Broadway, yet,
but, until then, we'll have
to settle for Chuck S,
aka Public Enema.
[ Laughter ]
I wonder if his kids got
vaccinated for embarrassment.
You know, I don't
always agree with Chuck,
but you do have to admire
how much he's enjoying himself.
Trump's gone,
Senate majority leader,
he's vaxxed, relaxed,
and living it to the max.
It's the summer of Chuck!
That's the life you could be
living, if you got vaccinated.
Unfortunately, there are still
too many prominent Republicans
lying about the vaccines
and bragging about the fact
that they won't get vaccinated,
like Wisconsin Senator
Ron Johnson,
who has suggested there might be
some sort of shadowy plot
behind the vaccine push,
or Senator Rand Paul,
who announced over the weekend
that he won't be
getting vaccinated.
Look, if you're
comfortable getting by
with what your body
produces on its own,
then you should take off that
regional theater wig of yours,
[ Laughter ]
Now, look, obviously,
you're allowed to make
your own personal decisions.
No one's going to strap you
to a gurney
and inject you with a vaccine.
This isn't
a "Clockwork Orange" situation,
even though Rudy Giuliani
does always look like
he's strapped to a chair
and being forced
to watch his scene in "Borat."
[ As Giuliani ]
How did I not know
it was a setup?!
Also, Senator, you're wrong,
about a bunch of things.
For one thing,
the CDC still recommends
getting vaccinated,
even if you had COVID.
And, perhaps most importantly,
as we already explained,
it's not just about you.
It's about preventing
transmission to others
and, as we just explained,
the evidence suggests
vaccines do that.
For some reason,
that's the point
these right-wingers
all refuse to acknowledge --
it's not just about you.
It's about protecting everyone.
And, yet, these people refuse,
either because they don't care
or because they have
the self-entitlement
of someone...
-Driving down the freeway
at 55 or 70 or 80 miles an hour.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS,
cancer, and other
serious illnesses
and they need your help,
now, more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the Donate button.
Stay safe.
Wear a mask.
Get vaccinated.
We love you.